fans of Netflix's squid game know just
how horrifying the candy game can be but
in the streamer reality competition
spin-off it might also make you lose
your lunge in the OG squid game the
second major game in a competition
stacked with impoverished people
fighting to the death for a massive cash
prize features doona candy popular in
South Korea with shapes carved into them
that players had to neatly
remove player four
456 pass if the shape remains intact
they live if it doesn't well you get it
players in Netflix's non-lethal reality
competition series squid game The
Challenge also attempt this feat and one
particular player Spencer fails in the
grossest way possible Spencer doesn't
start things off particularly well to be
honest other players identify him as
weak and in a confessional he admits
that he's very close with his mother is
afraid of most things and has a hard
time not believing everything he's told
I am extremely Gable it is a problem if
someone says something to me I'm going
to like believe it immediately when he
has to choose a desired candy shape for
his entire team Spencer disappoints them
all by ending up with the umbrella the
hardest shape to flawlessly carve by a
long shot I think some of them are going
to like remember me for the rest of
their life as a person who ruined their
chance of becoming a
millionaire things get a lot worse when
Spencer gets to carving though because
he starts gagging and seems to visibly
swallow his own vomit multiple times
that's right Spencer seems unable to
stop himself from gagging as a reflexive
reaction to the intense stress he's
under but he also pretty obviously
chokes back some chunks in the process
viewers with amobia the fear of vomiting
may want to fast forward through this
episode I can't look around or I might
puke so what happens to Spencer thanks
to his poor leadership skills obvious
fear and probably all that puke hanging
out in his mouth he breaks his candy and
is eliminating ated from the game the
poor guy curls into the fetal position
and simply waits for his fate
specifically for the squib indicating
that he's been eliminated from the game
to explode on his chest one has to
wonder why a soul as clearly sensitive
as Spencer would sign up for a reality
show based on a series where if you
break your candy you are executed on the
spot let's be honest about one thing
though and let poor Spencer off the hook
just a little bit the entire doona candy
game both in the original squid game and
in the Netflix reality show is
absolutely repulsive in order to even
start carving their shapes the players
have to spend an inordinate amount of
time licking the candy forget amapi
anyone with misophonia meaning people
with aversions to certain sounds like
eating will just hate this episode
outright back to Spencer For a Moment
besides the fact that he keeps choking
back a little bit of barf out of sheer
anxiety he's also just flat out drooling
into the tin containing his candy
although he's actually not alone in that
since it's not the worst strategy
watching this challenge in several
close-ups no less was a pretty harrowing
experience for even the most hardened of
viewers while everything that physically
happens to Spencer is extremely hard to
watch the whole challenge is a stomach
turning exercise for both the players on
screen and anybody queasily watching at
[Music]
home